MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO DURING THE COVID
PANDEMIC, YOU MAY REMEMBER, THE
GOVERNMENT TRIED TO SHUT DOWN
VIRTUALLY EVERY BUSINESS IN THE
COUNTRY, EXCEPT THE ONES THAT
PAY THEM BIG CAMPAIGN DONATIONS,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, LIQUOR
STORES, AMAZON AND GOOGLE.
AN ORGANIZATION THEY TRIED TO
SHUT DOWN WAS THE UFC, THE
FASTEST-GROWING SPORT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE JUST SAT DOWN WITH A MAN WHO
RUNS THE UFC, DANA WHITE, THE
PRESIDENT IN LAS VEGAS.
HE TOLD US WHY HE HELD FIGHTS
WHY WHY HE KEPT HIS BUSINESS
GOING, THE SPORT OPERATING,
DESPITE THE COVID SHUTDOWN.
WATCH.
>> THEY NEVER BUILT ANYTHING.
THEY DON'T -- NOBODY DEPENDS ON
THEM FOR A PAYCHECK.
BUT ALL THEY DO IS SIT BACK AND
CRITICIZE.
I'M GOING TO KILL PEOPLE.
I CARE MORE ABOUT MONEY THAN I
DO HUMAN LIFE.
I HEARD IT ALL.
AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES," AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE, WAS BLASTING ME
DAILY.
>> A LONG AND FASCINATING
INTERVIEW WITH DANA WHITE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHO DANA WHITE
IS, CERTAINLY THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL MAN IN SPORTS, AND A
SMART MAN.
WE'LL AIR THE WHOLE THING MONDAY
RIGHT HERE.
ALSO WORKING ON A DOCUMENTARY
COMING UP THIS WINTE